is there something different happening
to the brain to our compulsion with
social media is it right to even say
that social media is an addiction is it
a compulsion how do you pass all of this
apart yeah so I think social media is
similar in some ways and different in
other ways I guess no surprise right so
if we once again what's similar so the
most similar thing is that platforms are
developing things that are more engaging
it's just what they engage with varies
depending on not only the specific type
of game but games versus social media
and even within social media you'll see
different kinds of Engagement
so generally speaking social media
engages with a couple of things the most
important thing that social media
engages with is emotional activation
so if you think about why does a human
being switch from let's say Twitter to
Reddit or Reddit to Twitter or Twitter
to tick tock or Reddit to tick tock what
you tend to see is that if you're
emotionally engaged you're gonna stay on
and if you get bored that's when you
switch but what does boredom usually
mean people may think it's dopamine but
it's not actually dopamine because a lot
of people will use a lot of social media
even though they feel really bad and the
best example of this is some people will
like break up with their ex right and
then like late at night you're feeling
bad about yourself
and you start stalking your ex that
doesn't make you feel good that's not
dopamine then you see your ex out with
someone else who's more attractive than
you or maybe has a nicer car or
something like that and so a lot of
people will actually if you really
tunnel down and there's Research into
this that shows that what is the
emotional experience of engaging in
social media it's not always positive
so if you really look at like what kind
of social media crosses your
your feed it's stuff that's emotionally
engaging we're hearing about war we're
hearing about climate change we're
hearing about something in some news
organizations even like play into this
right where like fear-mongering is a
thing
and and so what we start to see is it's
really emotional engagement that social
media like really captures
um and so the people who are kind of
vulnerable to being emotionally engaged
will will sort of get caught up in
social media
another thing that we tend to see is
that the human identity and you kind of
alluded to this existential point
so like
social media allows us to create a
virtual identity and we can start to get
reinforcement of like these years of
millions of years of evolutionary
circuitry through the internet
so I want to be well respected in
Psychiatry or let's say in in a society
so I became a psychiatrist or medical
doctor and even then
as a medical doctor like there were
times in my life where I was kind of
thinking about well like is Psychiatry
like is that being a real doctor how
will I feel if I say I'm a neurosurgeon
which my my wife was like you should be
a neurosurgeon and like what does she
care she wants to introduce her husband
who's a neurosurgeon and I was like well
I've decided to do something close
it's in the same ballpark but it's a
little bit different
so we all crave the approval of other
human beings and now social media
quantifies that right
do people like me like normally the
human mind doesn't really know like
there's no way to measure it right you
sort of feel it but now I get a hundred
likes and someone else gets 200.
and so what social media really does is
captures a lot of that identity-focused
kind of people who are concerned about
being something self-esteem now we have
filters which sort of fix the problem
and make the problem worse which is
oftentimes what we see in in social
media so the more that I use filters
the better I feel about my presence on
the internet but each time I use a
filter
I'm not accepting the way that I look in
real life
and so it'll make the problem worse
which is why I think we see some a lot
of this like extreme filter using usage
that almost
doesn't you know seems like it isn't
real and people can kind of tell why do
people do that I think it's because they
kind of go down this rabbit hole
the comparison between are you having
fun now
and are you still using the technology
now it's so interesting because you know
I think about when I do get stuck Doom
scrolling through something and if I was
to ask myself that question you know
after 15 minutes probably or 20 minutes
on any social media I'm no longer having
fun
I spoke to huberman about this and I
thought this was a very interesting
reframe I'd love to get your thoughts on
this he sees social media usage more as
a compulsion than an addiction
in your opinion is there a meaningful
difference between the two do you
believe that this is the case does it
even matter whether it's the case or not
well I mean what what do you what how
are you defining the word compulsion
he said that it was more like a
compulsive action to pull the phone out
to look at it and to scroll to cycle
through all of the apps because I can't
remember his definition of addiction I
want to say it is uh
continuing to use a stimulus long after
the satisfactory nature of the stimulus
has been completed something like that
I'm going to guess that you'll know the
definition that I'm using yeah so let's
let's talk let's define things okay
so let's start by defining what is an
addiction
so the features of an addiction first of
all is that it impairs function so it
causes you some kind of damage and the
problem with addictions is that there
are solutions that fix a short-term
problem but damage things long term
so if we look at a lot of features of
addiction like let's say I'm addicted to
opiates and what opiates do is they make
me feel good temporarily but they cause
me problems because let's say I'm
stressed about work and I use an opiate
or I use marijuana or something like
that my stress goes away but
it doesn't fix any of my problems and if
I let's say get high today and then I
don't work on this project or whatever
like I I have one less day to work on it
so an addiction is is usually a behavior
that we engage in that despite the
damage that it does to us we continue to
engage in it now why do we engage in
addictions usually it's because they
provide some kind of relief or reward
and if we look at social media and video
games they're sort of very similar to
addictions in the sense that they
suppress negative emotional circuitry
which by the way is why it's more than
dopamine so even if you play a game for
eight hours let's say I'm ruining my
life and this is an experience that I
had firsthand right was failing out of
college and like how could I forget
failing out of college I could play
video games so it's not even that the
game is fun at eight or nine hours but
that suppression of the amygdala and the
limbic system is like kind of there so
we know that a lot of what makes video
games addictive is like the fact that
they
push problems away temporarily which is
very similar to all these other
substances like if I get drunk right I'm
not worried about anything
so in that way you know that's what an
addiction is
now a compulsion at least the the
technical term of like a clinical term
right so if we're talking about
obsessive compulsive disorder
in that way a compulsion is usually a
behavior that we engage in that has some
kind of effect on our cognition
so so it like it I have to do something
to make me feel a particular way
and what I would say is there's
absolutely like a habitual that's maybe
what I would use there's absolutely a
habitual or a conditioning aspect to
technology usage which they're very good
at and I don't know if you've ever had
this experience but this happens to me
all the time where I will realize that I
am not liking what I'm using like a
particular device for and then what I'll
do is close the app and then open it
right up again
so we are absolutely being conditioned
but this is also where if you kind of
look at it the circuitry is a little bit
different there's habit circuitry
there's dopamine reward circuitry
there's like suppressing our amygdala
and all of that stuff is active when it
comes to technology usage so I think
it's kind of like all of you above
presumably that's what makes it so
powerful the fact that you have all of
these different networks all coming
together into this perfect uh blend yeah
absolutely and why is it coming together
so so profoundly it's really interesting
because there's like there's almost this
darwinian slug match going on right now
between platforms
so if you look at like Tick Tock versus
YouTube shorts versus Instagram reels
versus
whatever Google's going to come up with
at some point or I guess they've got
YouTube shorts
um you know so what are all these
platforms doing they're actually
competing for your attention
the prize that they get is like your
mind
and so like whether Google wins Tick
Tock wins or Amazon wins or whoever wins
the one guaranteed thing is that there's
definitely going to be one loser and
that's actually you you are going to
lose control of your mind which is
exactly what happens
and even then I don't think the
platforms are evil I mean maybe they are
but that hasn't been my experience I
think it's just they have a product
right and everyone wants their eyes on
their product
and so what they're figuring out is how
can I engage people by tapping into a
different you know Circuit of the brain
how can I help condition someone to use
my app so it's not just about dopamine
it's not just about it's emotional
engagement it's dopamine it's habit
formation all that kind of stuff
even pings and notifications they're
good at that
given that we are hopelessly outgunned
up against billion dollar companies with
machine learning algorithms some of
which are the most powerful ever
designed in human history and an entire
team of software Engineers behind every
single button press how can people set
healthy boundaries around gaming and
social media
so I think thankfully we've we've got
a lot of good answers so I think this is
where prior to going to medical school I
spent seven years studying to become a
monk and the cool thing is that like
what the monks if you look at sort of
the Hindu and Buddhist traditions and
like meditation and mindfulness they
really figured out like how the mind
works and in a different way from like
the West so in the west we sort of
looked at a thousand different minds and
we sort of said okay if we average them
all together like what floats to the
surface but in the East they had sample
sizes of one so they're like okay how
can I understand where my desires come
from how can I get control of my desires
a lot of that stuff is kind of baked in
and what I actually find is the most
effective is starting with some of those
principles so understanding first of all
that all of Technology really causes one
problem
causes you to lose awareness
so anytime you get sucked in and in fact
this is why we want to use technology
right I want to go into a video game and
I want to get sucked into the video game
I want to binge watch shows so if you
look at like HBO and Netflix or whatever
right there they like really want us to
binge watch and we love binge watching
so if you look at the common element to
all these things it's a loss of
awareness
so the more that we can cultivate
awareness of things
the better off will be
and there's there's good evidence from
this from the world of Psychiatry as
well so if you look at like addiction
Psychiatry what we find is that if you
ask someone who relapses they'll say
yeah I was sober for six months and then
I don't know what happened
I just relapsed but what you really
discover and we sort of see this is that
people who are vulnerable to addiction
have a lack of awareness of their
internal emotional state and as
emotional stressors rise and rise and
Rise they like reach a particular
threshold that causes them to relapse so
a big part of what we do clinically when
we work with people is just raising
awareness
and so I'd say the first thing if you
want to set up healthy boundaries like
be aware of yourself why do you reach it
for it in the first place like are there
particular times of the day that you
reach for it
stuff like that
is there an emotional state that you
find yourself in that causes you to get
your phone out or to open up social
media on your laptop or to start
watching Netflix or to start playing a
video game absolutely so a simple
example of this is like if you think
about 30 years ago if I was trying to
study I would get distracted right I
wouldn't be able to focus on the
textbook and that's okay I would get
distracted for like a couple minutes I'm
sitting in a library I don't go anywhere
I don't do anything my mind wanders I
lose five minutes I lose 10 minutes and
then I come back to the text I'm like
all right time to get back to work now
what happens is even a 30 second
distraction I'm studying I pull out my
phone and I click a button and then my
mind is sucked into this like you know
pipeline of like attention grabbing
behavior and five minutes becomes three
hours
and so even a you know 30 second
attentional lapse now costs me an hour
of time
okay does that mean therefore that we
just need or the most robust solution to
stop yourself from using computers and
social media is to go places where you
don't have your phone and you don't have
video games is that the is that the most
robust tactic well so I mean I think
it's kind of like a lot of different
things right so we we
um I think it's first of all cultivating
more awareness of of the present and how
you feel and what your triggers are and
then at the other end they're absolutely
environmental aspects so one thing that
you know I'll tell people is that if
you're trying to get work done it's a
good idea to silence your phone or even
move it to the next room
um I I I'll tell people also like for
example if I'm working with patients who
are having trouble sleeping at night
to tell them hey keep your phone like at
the opposite end of the room or even
outside of your room and then everyone
sort of asks me like but what if there's
an emergency what if I get a phone call
in the middle of the night and then I
turn around and I ask them how many
times have you gotten a call in the last
two years that someone has needed your
help within five minutes
right and the answer is almost always
zero unless I'm working with a doctor in
which case like you know we have pagers
still
um so I think they're absolutely kind of
conditioning things or environmental
things that you can do using grayscale
being really aggressive with
notifications
um but also like the physical location
of your phone
and this is the other thing that that
platform developers are really good in
getting good at so if you think about
biometrics
the thing about Biometrics and face ID
is it actually reduces the time to
access your phone
so now even like the three seconds that
it used to take or two seconds to put in
your code now you just have to pick it
up and it it knows it's even that
friction has been removed yep that's
what they're doing removing all the
friction
okay so we have understanding your
triggers understanding the mental states
that you get into the emotional states
that you're in
um whether it's been a hard day at work
whether this is some sort of coping
mechanism because things are stressful
or you're just tired or whatever what
are the precursors that happen before
you then descend into using technology
in a way which
after the event you reflect on and wish
that you hadn't done there are some
environmental cues and factors that we
can use uh distance being one of them in
that you can't use a screen that you
can't put your hands on or see so
keeping it away sleeping with your phone
outside of the bedroom is there anything
else when it comes to good boundaries
what are the other longest levers yeah
so I think the other thing to consider
is that so we think about this as like a
problem that has a solution we don't
think about boundaries as skills that
are
built up right so if you think about
like a muscle like how do I lift more
weight I need to maybe do more weight
lifting and if you kind of think about
how do I hold a boundary against a
technology that is becoming more and
more invasive you get stronger at
holding boundaries so what I'll do is
I'll also give people exercises and this
largely comes from the meditative
tradition so you can like formally sit
down and meditate but there's a lot of
exercises that you can develop based on
the theory of meditation my favorite
thing to have people do is no more
phones in bathrooms
so like everyone takes their phone to
the bathroom now and if you just like
think about it like if I like say that
and people are listening to that the
instinctive reaction is going to be like
oh my God don't take that thing away but
like what are you gonna lose what am I
gonna do while I'm pooping Dr K you're
gonna do what human beings have done for
millions of years prior to the
development of Technology with the poop
just be with it so so what's happened in
our society as a whole is we have become
intolerant to boredom yes so if you want
to get control over every bit of
technology in your life you have to
learn how to not fear boredom and give
yourself small doses of boredom you know
don't take an audio book the next time
you go for a walk or don't listen to
music or something like that right and
and just start to like pick particular
discrete things don't watch things while
you eat
um so so there are all kinds of things
that you can sort of set kind of certain
lines and then really practice those and
then your mind will literally become
stronger so your ability to restrain
your attention and tolerate boredom will
increase is that something that you see
reflected neurologically
psychologically is this something that
actually shows up in the literature
somehow oh absolutely so so one simple
example in so many ways so let's talk
about literature in different ways so
the first thing is let's talk about
let's say psychological literature
so we know that for example people with
ADHD
have difficulty restraining their
impulses and they tend to get highly
distracted so we know that meditation
for example helps people with
impulsivity and improving Focus that we
kind of know if you sort of think about
it what is the practice of meditation
it's like literally practicing focusing
on a neurological level we know that
there are brain correlates with things
like ADHD like frontal lobe dysfunction
so the frontal lobes are Master Control
parts of the brain that they can sort of
restrain and direct our attention
and so what happens when we do things
like meditate or some of these practices
is that we learn how to like it
strengthens our frontal lobes there's
even data that shows that it strengthens
sort of the inhibitory circuits of the
brain so our frontal lobes can go and
put the brakes on a particular impulse
and then even if we're talking about old
old old literature so we're talking
about the Sanskrit literature from like
5000 years ago
there's this this one thing there's this
one principle called
which means focusing on one thing at a
time and thousands of years ago they
were like hey here's a technique to
focus on just one thing at a time and
you can kind of practice just doing one
thing at a time
and so there's a lot of scientific stuff
from everywhere from Clinical literature
to basic science literature to even like
old stuff we'll get back to talking to
Dr Kane one minute but first I need to
tell you about manscaped if you're a
gentleman who needs to trim his
sensitive areas and you are still using
an old face shaver from five Christmases
ago what are you doing join us here in
the modern world there are purpose-built
tools for the job and the manscape
lawnmower 4.0 is the greatest ball and
body hair trimmer ever created it
features a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents a 90 minute
battery which allows you to take a
longer shave or if you're just a
particularly hairy gentleman waterproof
technology which allows you to groom in
the shower and an LED light which
illuminates grooming areas for a closer
and more precise trim or if you just
want to do it at night perhaps it's also
got a wireless charging system to help
the battery last even longer but best of
all you can get 20 off everything
site-wide from manscaped and free
shipping if you go to manscaped.com
Modern wisdom and use the code modern
wisdom at checkout that's manscaped.com
modern wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face